[Music]
all right let's go to ray in
san diego california hey what's going on
ray how are we doing
hi john thanks for having me on thanks
for calling thanks for calling thanks
for calling so what's up how can i help
um well i uh recently just found out
that my husband was
having like an
inappropriate texting relationship with
a co-worker
and i'm not really sure
how to
uh
i guess repair the trust loss he seems
very
remorseful
you know says that he made a mistake but
i'm just not really sure how to trust
him again where to go from here yeah man
i'm sorry so
um whenever somebody says it was an
inappropriate relationship i
in the past have jumped all over it and
then realized oh that was different than
i thought so paint me a picture of what
inappropriate was what was actually
going back and forth
so they were
talking
i guess about having a physical
relationship through text
she was offering to send him
inappropriate pictures
okay
it never got to that point are you sure
are you sure
yes i am sure i did look
she said that she was going to do it
over a snapchat and never did i did look
okay so and he cut it off at that point
okay so he got it got a little bit
over his skis and he got nervous and cut
it off
yes he said that if he had received
those pictures he would have known that
it would have crossed a different line
of inappropriate gotcha okay
so how long have you all been married
um it'll be seven years uh next year at
the beginning of the year so
about six and a half okay
um
so you asked the question how do you
rebuild trust
how do you repair this and as i talk
through here i want to keep in mind two
important things number one at the end
of the day as much as this how hard this
is to hear
you can only
control you
okay and
the repair of any the healing i don't
like to use the word repair because it's
not a machine but the healing of any
relationship takes two people
and what that means is you have to risk
you've got to go all in
and hope he goes all into
okay so keep that in mind as we talk
through this so the big question number
one is do you wanna trust him again or
are you done
i do want to trust him again i don't
really want to
end our
family over it okay
so
tell me what you feel
and here's what i mean by that are you
angry
are you scared that you almost lost him
are you frustrated because
once you heard about this you could see
yeah i've seen two years where we've
been disconnected i haven't done this
and and i haven't
been open in this way and i've i've i've
been putting off conversations and all
of a sudden
or do you feel just raged out that
everything's been so great in your life
and then this guy went and did that like
what are you feeling
i'm a little confused because
we weren't
going through anything rough we weren't
having any hard times
we were both
you know what i thought was happy even
he said like there's nothing wrong
in our marriage he doesn't know why you
do that
so i'm confused and you know angry that
he would do that
but
it's all just kind of a big question
mark in my head right now yeah for sure
for sure
so um
somebody i i turn to often when i'm
trying to wrap my head around new ways
and old ways of looking at
infidelity whether it's just thoughts we
have and never even send a text message
or texting that all of a sudden gets out
of control and all of a sudden we're
meeting up with somebody never meant or
infidelity like someone's just a serial
cheater and they've been having
they've been you know having physical
intimate relationships with other people
for years and years and years esther
perel
gives me she's a great um she's just a
great thought leader when it comes to
thinking about these things rethinking
about these things some things i
vehemently disagree with her on but that
does stretch my thinking and other
things she's just right on so one of the
things she talks about that was
important for me years ago and i was
thinking through this for the first time
wrestling with
how do people with quote unquote great
marriages end up in these other
situations
and she reports that in almost every
client she interacts with who's who's
had some sort of breach in the trust of
their marriage
every bit of research she's been a part
of
the word that comes up always is the
word alive
that the person who is involved in a
texting relationship the person who has
fantasies about somebody else's husband
or wife the person who
goes through it and has intimate
relationships outside of the bounds of
their committed relationship
they always come back and say it made me
feel alive
and here's where that's so important
is that
often we think or the narrative we've
been told about cheating is that there
must be something wrong with the
relationship there must be something
wrong with you
or your husband may not must not like
you or something you're doing
and that's why he went and did this
and what she's come back and said is
that's actually not right at all
he doesn't like something about him
he doesn't like who he's become in this
relationship
now it might be because
guys will say all sorts of stupid things
um
wives will say all sorts of stupid
things well it's because of this and the
towels and the way
it's i got sick of always coming home
frustrated
i got sick of always coming home to a
routine i got sick of coming home to
us introducing sex intimacy in the exact
same way in the exact same time
and this person made me feel alive i got
sick of coming home and nobody ever
recognizes my contribution to the house
they just take me for granted and and
and this person at work said dude you
are killing it on these reports
and suddenly my heart fluttered a little
bit nothing to do with romance nothing
to do with sex i just felt for the first
time in one year two years 10 years 30
years
i felt alive i felt that guy look at me
in a way that my husband hasn't looked
at me in years
it's about alive and
luckily for the your relationship and i
say that intentionally
your husband got real close to the edge
and peered way over
and at the last second was like no i'm
not gonna cross this line
and so
he did violate your he was keeping
secrets from you things got out of
control all that's true and real
and
okay none of these things are excuses by
the way this is just a context for i'm
trying to give you some ideas for this
confusion
i think this is way more about him than
it is about you
okay okay
now
he may not like the way he felt around
you because he doesn't think you're this
or you're not doing those things or what
that's secondary to
man something about this got his heart
racing again
that he felt in a way that he might not
have felt since y'all were dating or
since y'all were in year two or you're
whatever so
what does trust look like for you what
do you when you say i just want to trust
him what does that mean
i guess not worrying about you know
who he's talking to now okay um what
he's doing when he's you know not at
work not at home
uh
he his job just kind of requires me to
have a lot of trust in him
so is he on the road on the road a lot
is he traveling people yeah okay he he
works away from home
um he travels for work so he's gone a
few days a week
okay
and
if you are honest with yourself
can you trust him
i think i can
i mean like you know if you can or can't
like do you trust you think can you
trust him or no
yeah okay
are you safe for him
meaning if you sat down and said
this [ __ ] on the radio
said that often when people find
themselves
in situations outside of their marriages
it's about them feeling alive
for the first time them feeling like
they're funny again they're feeling like
they are attractive again they're
feeling like they are capable again
tell me about how you felt when you were
texting back and forth
are you a safe place that he could tell
that be honest and truthful with you
yes because we're going back to things
that only you can control now okay
so if you sat down and said hey tell me
about what was just in your head could
you hear that
or it would just fill you up with rage
he would tell me he would tell you
awesome yeah
so
here's what uh where you guys have a
magic moment year seven
that's a that's a notorious tough year
for folks years seven to ten that's when
we start to go oh this is who we are
and this is the way things are gonna be
do you have any little ones
yes we have two okay how old are they
uh one is five and the other is almost
two there you go so this is just gonna
be our life
um we're gonna always be wiping butts
and
um we're always gonna be having sex in
the dark as quick as possible so we can
go to sleep so we can get back up and
make a new bottle and make a new thing
and we're not gonna go on dates
whatever that is
this year seven to ten is when it starts
to slowly
feel like this is the rest of our life
and this is a season when lots of these
things pop up either there's been some
infidelity for years it just finally
goes you know what i'm not doing this
anymore or this is when somebody starts
to go i feel dead on the inside for
whatever reason
and so
what i want you guys to look at this
opportunity as
a
like the matrix a really close near-miss
was there a violation for sure
um did your husband violate your trust a
thousand percent yes
but it didn't explode
there's not blood on the ceiling
oh my gosh it got close and this is a
moment y'all can choose and you've heard
me say this a hundred times
you can excavate the whole thing
and say
how do we choose to lean into
feeling alive with each other again how
do we to use esther perel's language how
do we practice desire
i want to re fall in love with you i
want to become a guy that makes your
heart flutter again
i want to become a
partner that makes you
think about me all day and when you're
traveling i'm gonna make it hard for you
to do your job without wanting to come
home and be with me and that's not just
a sexual thing that is just a friendship
communication and a sexual thing of
course but how do we rebuild that
because we've lost it we've been
together for seven years we're changing
diapers we're tired we're this and that
i'm not
i'm not even showering anymore and
all my pants have stretchy things on
them men and this is both of you all
right i get home from being out of town
and i just leave my
suitcase in a pile on the floor and my
clothes just stay there until i race
through to watch them again for my next
trip out like how do we reimagine this
thing
and i want you to lean in on two things
number one
what do you both need to feel alive
again
and be honest with each other be open
with each other
and the second thing is what are the
boundaries you need to reestablish trust
meaning i need you when you get home i
want you to unlock your phone for the
next six months next year
like i want you just to put the phone
down or we're all gonna have the same
code
if you have any i'm asking you to not
have any extra email accounts i want you
to delete them
i'm asking you to facetime me or if
somebody if you text another
um another person who's attracted to you
if you text another woman
i want you to let me know that that
exchange happened
every single time
and that's his responsibility to lean
into your boundaries
and so you're going to have to risk by
putting your boundaries out there and
saying i need you to meet these because
he might say i'm not doing that
and now you have another layer peeled
back of your relationship
i hear in your voice you don't think
that's the case you think he'll do
whatever you say is that right
yes it seems
really remorseful he said he would do
whatever it took to fix this awesome so
you be honest about your boundaries and
you may need to sit down and talk to
somebody you may need to go out with a
friend and just vent and you all write
down on a piece of paper be so clear
here's the boundaries here's what's
going to make me feel safe
and
know that he's practicing trust you're
practicing trust
and when you get a text from him in four
months and it's like hey
my boss she texted me and let me know
that i need to be at work tomorrow at
eight and you go i don't care that's
when you'll know
okay or when he
texts you and says hey we're all going
to lunch
and
um
there's going to be three of my female
colleagues and just me are you okay with
that and you're like why would i yes i
don't care that's when you'll know and
if it's a year from now or two years
from now and you say
not a good idea i don't feel right about
that you'll let him know and he'll go
great cool no problem
is that
you see what i'm leaning into
it's creating a safe place y'all can
talk about being alive and it's creating
a safe place where you can your
boundaries can be heard and he can lean
into him and just know it's gonna be
frustrating because this is all new and
he's gonna forget to text once and he's
gonna catch himself and send it
understand that he's practicing and
trying
and you're practicing and trying to i
think this
this might be one of those moments that
launches your relationship into a new
stratosphere
and you can not just say things are
going great i want you to be able to
define great
what is this thing that we are creating
who are we going to be why are we doing
this
and how can we both work together to let
the other one feel alive does that sound
exciting
yes it does and that's
really good ideas of what to do that
kind of answers my question there
awesome just not a
bridge i've gone over before yeah hey
we're in it now you're in and out and
you're committed and he sounds like he's
committed
this is perfect this is perfect
go excavate the whole thing
and y'all go out somewhere dream about
what this can look like and again when
y'all go out this isn't a punishment
session for him this isn't you gonna
take him out and be like and i did this
sounds like you've had that conversation
this is you saying
something about this made you feel alive
and i want you to feel alive with me
and i want to feel alive again with you
and we've got these two kids that we
love dearly
and they have taken much of our life
with them and so it's our job to
recreate desire to recreate intimacy to
recreate laughter and sexuality and
commitment and
aliveness
and i don't even think aliveness is a
word but y'all can create it in your
house who cares
so great i want to know how this
conversation goes so have this
conversation build something cool draw
the blueprints and begin building and
then write me back and let me know how
things are going ray thank you so much
for your vulnerability